[Música]
y
la izquierda llegó al poder en colombia
gustavo petro de la coalición pacto
histórico conquistó al electorado que le
dio 11 2 millones de votos tras una
reñida campaña presidencial llena de
escándalos una campaña muy larga
desgastante y donde brilló el
señalamiento y el desprestigio antes que
la puesta en común de ideas y los planes
de acción son muchos los factores que
pueden analizarse que puedan explicar el
por qué colombia eligió a gustavo petro
como su nuevo presidente el desgaste del
discurso de la derecha el deseo de un
cambio el aumento de la pobreza y la
desigualdad la polarización reinante en
la sociedad colombiana la falta de
implementación del acuerdo de paz
también la insatisfacción por falta de
oportunidades son factores que pueden
haber llevado al estallido social que
vimos hace un año entre los estudiantes
colombianos y que petro apoyo en cierta
medida pero hoy tras su elección deja
claro que el pueblo quiere algo
diferente y que debe ser escuchado
veamos el resumen de la jornada en el
siguiente informe
me llamo
gustavo petro
[Aplausos]
y su presidente
un momento histórico para colombia con
más de 11,2 millones de votos el
izquierdista gustavo petro ganó la
presidencia después de varios intentos
por llegar a la casa de nariño superó a
su oponente por alrededor de 700 mil
votos en unas elecciones con la
participación electoral más alta en los
últimos 20 años
22,6 de los 39 millones de colombianos
salieron a las urnas el equivalente al
58 por ciento de participación al
conocer los resultados
gustavo petro dio su primer discurso
como mandatario el cambio significa que
esta esperanza
puede hacer y llenar todos los rincones
del territorio nacional el izquierdista
tuvo la victoria principalmente en las
regiones costera del país aunque bogotá
la capital se desmarcó del centro de
colombia y aportó más de 2.2 millones de
votos al triunfo de petró las elecciones
más o menos
mostraron dos colombias
cercanas en términos de votos
nosotros queremos que colombia en medio
de su diversidad sea una colombia a
parte del histórico logro de la
izquierda en el poder es la primera vez
que el país sudamericano tiene una
vicepresidenta mujer afrodescendiente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
saludo a las mujeres de colombia a todas
mis hermanas
mis comadres
gracias por haberme acompañado vamos las
mujeres a erradicar el patriarcado en
nuestro país pero también se refirió a
los más de 10 millones de votantes de su
oponente rodolfo hernández dijo que
quiere desarrollar el capitalismo del
país y aseguró que espera posicionar a
colombia como una potencia en
latinoamérica
[Música]
la llegada de petro al poder cambiar
nuevamente el mapa político en la región
de américa latina' históricamente
colombia ha sido el aliado más fuerte
que tiene eeuu en estas regiones
prácticamente el punto de partida y de
llegada de la política de seguridad de
washington en la región de américa
latina'
las reacciones ante el triunfo de petró
no se hicieron esperar veamos te quiero
mucho en colombia triunfo de la
izquierda
el candidato del pacto histórico gustavo
petro ganó la segunda vuelta
presidencial con 54% de los votos y las
reacciones de los dirigentes
latinoamericanos llegaron de norte a sur
con una alusión a la literatura
colombiana el presidente mexicano andrés
manuel lópez obrador celebró la victoria
el triunfo de gustavo petro es histórico
los conservadores de colombia siempre
han sido tenaces y duros el escritor
josé maría vargas vila relataba que los
dictadores de su pais mojaban en agua
bendita su puñal antes de matar
desde honduras la presidenta ción mara
castro felicitó al pueblo colombiano en
nombre del pueblo de honduras felicitó
al valiente pueblo de colombia por
elegir el histórico cambio social que
representa hoy el presidente electo
gustavo petro suramérica también se
llenó de reacciones el mandatario
venezolano nicolás maduro reconoció el
triunfo de petró desde el país vecino
felicitó a gustavo petro y a france a
márquez por la histórica victoria en las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia se
escuchó la voluntad del pueblo
colombiano que salió a defender el
camino de la democracia y la paz
y desde la frontera occidental lo hizo
el presidente ecuatoriano guillermo
lasso ha felicitado telefónicamente ha
gustado petro por su elección como
presidente de nuestra hermana república
de colombia y reitera la disposición de
nuestro gobierno para fortalecer la
amistad y cooperación priorizando el
desarrollo y la integración de nuestros
pueblos también aplaudió la victoria de
petró el más reciente presente izquierda
de la región gabriel boric acabo de
hablar con gustavo petro para
felicitarlo por su triunfo en la
presidencia de la colombia junto a
francia márquez alegría para américa
latina
haremos juntos por la unidad de nuestro
continente en los desafíos de un mundo
que cambia velozmente seguimos con el
triunfo de petró américa latina' da un
paso más hacia la izquierda con una
decena de mandatarios que comparten
dicha ideología que viene entonces para
colombia podrá gustavo petro
distensionar la polarización y ese
malestar que se siente en las calles
colombianas podrá su política de amor
que está basada en la esperanza el
diálogo y la comprensión tal y como lo
dijo en su discurso después de darse a
conocer su triunfo será esto suficiente
para llevar el esperado y necesario
cambio que quieren los colombianos en
materia económica en materia de la
pobreza de medio ambiente y
oportunidades quienes serán entonces sus
aliados y cómo se comportará la
oposición en colombia hoy en el debate
de france 24 colombia como gobernar a la
izquierda ese es nuestro tema para el
día de hoy y para conversar y analizar
lo hemos invitado a mónica pachón ella
es directora o mejor doctora en ciencias
políticas y docentes de la universidad
de los andes que está en la ciudad de
bogotá y también se une a este análisis
theodor can él es analista político y
control risks ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
temas preguntas y cuestionamientos lo
que quieran decir a través de las redes
sociales en facebook instagram twitter
también pueden ver nuestra señora en
streaming a través de youtube no se
encuentran como france24 bajo ese arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta cerrada recuerdo es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas
bueno mónica es a quien le doy la
bienvenida al programa ya es un gusto
para mí conversar con usted sobre este
tema de la política colombiana y bueno
usted ya lo sabe como la dinámica de
este programa nuestra primera pregunta
es el punto de partida para conocer
posiciones y mi punto de partida pues es
con la que cerraba la introducción cómo
va a gobernar la izquierda colombia y
que representa para colombia el triunfo
de la izquierda
bueno muchísimas gracias por esta
invitación ha sido una jornada
extenuante
el ciclo electoral que acaba de cerrar
el día de ayer creo que la izquierda ha
propuesto en colombia un acuerdo
nacional ayer
gustavo petro en su alocución
presidencial su frente su
discurso mencionaba que quería unir las
dos colombias para mí no es claro
digamos
y fue muy ambiguo el discurso en
términos concretos para unir las dos
colombias pero creo que el presidente
gustavo petro e intentó durante la
última semana de su campaña hacer
acuerdos ahí vemos antanas mockus en las
imágenes estaba alejandro gaviria y
estaban otros líderes políticos con los
que no estaba inicialmente
planteando
alternativas y sobre todo dándole
tranquilidad a un electorado que tiene
temor por gustavo petro y por sus
políticas macroeconómicas y fiscales
y ahora la bienvenida a theodore también
él se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá
gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa punto de partida la misma
pregunta cómo podrá gobernar la
izquierda y qué significa para colombia
el triunfo de gustavo petro y de la
izquierda en este país
bueno muchas gracias es pasear es un
gusto estar aquí con ustedes este
programa es bueno yo voy a empezar con
alguna pregunta
que es el significativo en este triunfo
de la izquierda y bueno yo creo que ahí
es importante
destacar
como logro gustavo petro esta votación
impresionante de más de 16 millones de
votos que vimos ayer y yo creo que si
vemos donde más incremento votos entre
primera y segunda vuelta vemos que entre
bogotá antioquia y valle de cauca
incremento más de millón de votos entre
la primera y la segunda vuelta y eso
para mí indica que él logró atraer gran
parte de las personas que votaron por
sergio fajardo
e incluso otros candidatos en la primer
voto eso implica un poco como mencionar
la armónica que o sea ya este temor que
o de izquierda o sea ya no es un factor
tan determinante y realmente hay mucho
lanzamiento de relación que está abierto
ya a un cambio y un gobierno de la
izquierda bueno ustedes como el pienso
yo que que va a gobernar pues si vemos
el programa que ha tanteado estado petro
fiscalmente es un programa que contempla
cambio estás ante radicales en muchas
áreas
pero qué problemas destacar tres primero
quiere transitar desde un enfoque de una
independencia incluso económica en las
industrias extractivas hacia un modelo
económico muy diferente
basado en industrias de conocimiento por
otro lado tiene una visión mucho más
proteccionista e intervencionista de dar
con envidias de mayor edad economía y
por otro lado contempla un rol mucho más
fuerte para el sector público
en áreas en sectores sociales como
pensiones y salud yo creo que no va a
ser posible lograr todo esto entonces
efectivamente va a tener que
buscar alianzas moderar algunas de esas
propuestas para poder lograr reformas
legislativas
y porque va a ser determinante que
sigamos como es esta relación con los
ingresos porque si no tiene éxito en el
congreso entonces esto digamos
para mí te va a tener que buscar otras
vías
ampliando de más en digamos acciones
administrativas y ejecutivas si esto
podría generar ciertas atenciones
eso me lleva a la siguiente pregunta un
tenedor que va en línea con lo que usted
ha estado diciendo unidad nacional dijo
gobernar con todos en un país tan
polarizado y tan dividido y donde hay
tanto peso de algunas figuras políticas
será posible para el conformar esos
consensos para poder gobernar
es necesario esos consensos como ustedes
ya lo ha dicho están en esa necesidad de
formar coaliciones alianzas para para
poder llevar a cabo todo este plan tan
ambicioso será posible en el escenario
político que usted conoce bien en este
país será posible
pues yo creo que si es posible en
ciertas propuestas y ahí creo que hay
que vivir un poco por por sectores y
analizar un poco las propuestas
de forma independiente entonces yo creo
que yo creé destacados áreas en que yo
creo que sí va a ser posible llegar a
acuerdos no va a ser fácil pero lo que
sí veo una ventana de autoridad y esos
son la reforma tributaria y creo que hay
un gran consenso de que hay una reforma
tributaria estructural es necesaria y yo
creo que muchos digo que ha planteado
gustavo petro en ese sentido y puede
tener apoyo entre diversos sectores
políticos incluyendo algunos partidos
del centro entonces es una área que hay
que mirar muy bien cómo es la evolución
de esto se han ido otro creo que los
temas de pensiones que también veo una
ventana de oportunidad el espacio de
acuerdo entre lo que está proponiendo
porque no petro y por qué podría apoyar
algunos partidos más centralistas de los
planes o mónica su opinión sobre esta
necesidad de gobernar con todos
para todos será posible estos dos puntos
que nos presenta theodor si usted quiere
añadir algo más o su punto de vista
claro bienvenido muchas gracias yo creo
que la atención realmente es muy fuerte
y estamos en un vamos fue una campaña
muy agresiva el
presidente gustavo petro fue muy radical
en algunas propuestas en industrias
extractivas como mencionaba theodor y la
intervención del estado en mercados
privados como son el de las pensiones el
de la salud que efectivamente
requerirían un cambio de la estructura
del estado y de la provisión del bien
público muy muy impresionante
además de proponer el cierre
específicos a unos a unos negocios de
industrias extractivas que son muy
importantes para colombia son 20
millones de 16 a 20 billones de pesos
anuales que representan una tercera
parte del presupuesto de inversión
entonces yo creo que hay una oportunidad
para moderarse pero esta oportunidad
también representa
ajustar las expectativas de sus
electores frente al congreso de la
república creo que va a ser un reto
armar una coalición mayoritaria y le va
a tocar ir paso por paso creo que la
reforma tributaria es un buen ejemplo de
algo que podrían en que podrían estar en
acuerdo a varios partidos pero hay otros
temas en los que yo no veo que gustavo
petro pueda cumplirle a sus electores
como por ejemplo cuál mónica
pues está hablando por ejemplo de tener
un
proceso de paz con el nn
y ahí la derecha es mucho más radical
que destruir o eliminar las ips que son
ese intermediario privado para prestar
el servicio de salud a y el sector
privado yo diría que
estaría reaccionando fuertemente en
contra y también creo que hay una
hay unas promesas de subsidios cierto y
de gasto estatal que es que son
extraordinarios y que requerirían que el
estado fuera muchísimo más grande y
muchísimo más potente y no y en este
momento no lo podemos hacer sin
comprometer la estabilidad fiscal y
macroeconómica del país
mónica usted cree que hay una gran
presión sobre francia market y sobre
gustavo petro hay muchísima expectativa
en torno a cómo puede ser este gobierno
no solamente por ser el primer gobierno
izquierda sino porque es un
un personaje político dentro de la
escena colombiana que este es su tercer
intento por llegar a la presidencia y lo
ha logrado ha dado la batalla a lo largo
de los últimos años por llegar hasta la
casa de nariño hay muchísima expectativa
puede existir también cierto porcentaje
como de desánimo por parte del
electorado en unos meses con respecto a
gustavo petro como por ejemplo está
pasando en chile donde la popularidad de
boris ha comenzado a bajar hay cierto
descontento ya hubo manifestaciones en
las calles por parte de los estudiantes
que incluso fueron los que apalancaron a
este personaje de boris en la escena
política chilena usted quiere que pronto
podemos vivir ese un escenario similar
hay una diferencia importante entre esas
elecciones de elección colombiana
gustavo petro es un personaje que
aglomera a esos votantes esos votantes
han sido fieles durante las tres
elecciones son votantes que realmente
defienden ha gustado petro
independientemente de lo que ocurra es
acá le llamamos como esta popularidad de
flor no salió en escándalos salen
relaciones de gustado petro con
políticos super tradicionales
cuestionamientos y eso no le genera
ningún problema que puede pasar yo creo
que en el corto plazo en la movilización
social tiende a calmarse ya proteger a
gustavo petro
pero si gustavo petro no
presenta resultados en yo diría en un
año y medio
además de su discurso que es efectivo o
persuasivo y envíen amor a sus votantes
puede terminar en un escenario similar
bueno el escenario de una política de
teflón es muy habitual en colombia no
solamente para petro sino para otros
candidatos y otros personajes de la
política nacional lo hemos visto con el
ex presidente uribe escándalos subidas y
bajadas en su popularidad y se mantiene
con un círculo muy cerrado de seguidores
es algo particular de la política
colombiana theodor no me olvido de usted
ya pasó a preguntarle sobre algo que
usted estaba mencionando en cuanto a la
votación yo lo llamo el voto periférico
y por qué lo llamo así y es porque la
gran zona donde se concentra la
población colombiana y dónde está la
mayor parte de la industria la zona
desarrollada de colombia es el área
andina es el centro del país si uno ve
la votación que de gustavo petro el
triunfo en los departamentos en las
regiones que rodean esa zona del centro
que tradicionalmente históricamente y
lamentablemente son las zonas más pobres
de este país la costa el pacífico parte
de la población que está en la amazona
en la costa atlántica que tiene muchos
problemas de infraestructura
qué análisis se puede hacer de esta
votación además tuvo que haber sido una
votación muy alta para poder
contrarrestar a la alta población que
vive en la zona central que es donde se
concentra la mayor cantidad de
habitantes
bueno yo creo que hay dos dinámicas
distintas un poco detrás de esta
gran votación que obtuvo petro en ayer
he probado es la dinámica que menciona
que tiene que ver y vamos con el mapa
electoral según quién ganó en tu voto
parlamento es cierto y allí se ve
claramente que petro ganó en la costa
caribe en específico y en general en
estos departamentos que han sido esto
ricamente marginalizados y en general o
sea tienen tasas de pobreza del
desempleo más autoridad promedio en
cambio luego fernández siga no digamos
en el centro del centro de país de ambos
individuos del departamentos más
dinámicos económicamente del país es
actualmente es un dinámico y allí en
donde petro que se hagan ganadores
nuestro elementos donde que otorga no
son precisamente de los departamentos
que más incremento en contra la
participación
primera de segunda vuelta pues vemos
claramente que el mensaje de petro y el
cambio a un modelo socioeconómico que
está ofreciendo
probablemente en logró atraer muchos
votantes e incluso nuevos votantes entre
primera y segunda vuelta en estos
departamentos pero por otro lado y
apuntó que estaba haciendo
ahorita también logró grandes números de
votantes y un incremento grande en
votantes esto récord de petró
en bogotá y en departamentos como valle
de cauca y antioquia en curso pues no
gana durante aunque actualmente pero sí
logró incrementar por
pues por por más de 200 mil votos entre
el primero y 54 yo creo que eso es un
señal de nuestro apoyo en digamos
grandes ciudades centro el voto de
opinión entonces eso es como otro y
d'amico que cree que creo que es
importante y ayuda a explicar su enorme
crecimiento entre el primerísimo the
water si cuando entre la primera vuelta
y la segunda se
decía en muchos análisis que petro ya
había tocado techo que ya no iba a
lograr conseguir esos 2 millones o poco
más de votos que necesitaba para poder
conquistar la presidencia claramente
ayer quedó completamente desvirtuado ese
supuesto techo que había ya alcanzado
pasó a preguntarle por un punto
importante visto fuera de las fronteras
colombianas es un tema que llama mucho
la atención para los que han seguido
este proceso electoral theodor y es que
la economía del miedo como lo han
titulado algunos en algunos miedos en
algunos medios de comunicación
internacionales y es la incertidumbre
que hay en torno al sector económico al
sector del empresariado y las
inversiones de los extranjeros en
colombia y que tan tranquilos pueden
estar en este sector con la elección de
gustavo petro hay quienes dicen que
el primer paso que tiene que hacer esta
semana es decir quién va a ser ese
ministro de hacienda el que va a llevar
las riendas de la economía para poder
tranquilizar un poco los mercados el
dólar se disparó las bolsas están
subiendo y bajando hay mucha
incertidumbre que se puede decir al
respecto
y yo creo que es ayudar de que haya más
incertidumbre por parte de los
empresarios y los selección istas con
petro
yo creo que simplemente vamos a ver una
reacción los mercados ya estamos viendo
una reacción los mercados yo creo que en
cuanto a los pasos que queda hacer yo
creo que si va a nombrar digamos un
equipo económico de técnico gente con
mucha experiencia gente que de alguna
forma dan tranquilidad a los mercados
pues yo creo que sí va a dedicar el
equipo económico en puestos claves
digamos que tienen un perfil que es o
sea que decir que tranquiliza de buena
forma los mercados los empresarios pero
yo creo que en el verano segunda gran
interrogante va a ser un poco como
maneja digamos a tensiones internas en
el gobierno de petró entre estas bolsas
más moderadas que seguramente van a
estar y las bolsas de divididas voces un
poco digamos más radicales y también van
a estar dentro de esta condición
entonces ese poco porque esa visión a
moreno que existe así el busca digamos
alianzas con una versión liberados y
busca poder sus propuestas pues eso
puede generar digamos alguna resistencia
alguna alguna tensión con otros sectores
con otros voces dentro de su gobierno y
como se resuelva esta atención ya más va
a ser clave determinar el rumbo sobre
todo económico de decisión gobierno
mónica desde su punto de vista algún
punto para aclarar sobre lo que ha hecho
teodoro añadir y si está en riesgo este
modelo económico que ha tenido colombia
los últimos años que claramente de
acuerdo a los indicadores de pobreza de
crecimiento de desigualdad pues no ha
sido un modelo exitoso porque la pobreza
siga creciendo la desigualdad sigue
aumentando se
está en riesgo este modelo ese es el
gran temor de los empresarios en
colombia
pues yo creo que el riesgo si existe
porque porque nosotros vivimos una
crisis económica importante y vivimos un
gobierno que al final de la historia
toma la decisión de ser y de ser más
heterodoxo generando una tasa de
inflación que no habíamos visto en el no
ser de cada cierto una inflación es
mayores al 10% inflación es que
equivalen al 20 por ciento en los
alimentos que efectivamente es un
impuesto regresivo a la pobreza entonces
cuando se habla de incrementar el estado
incrementar los salarios hacer este tipo
de actividades que incrementan el tamaño
del estado sin que el estado
necesariamente tenga la capacidad
estábamos hablando de una política macro
que puede afectar directamente los
mercados y la población en general yo
creo que colombia está dividida pero no
necesariamente dividida en torno a lo
que fue la división álvaro uribe y el
resto sino que creo que en la división
que he gustado petro estableces una
división en donde la gente que está en
contra de gustavo petro tiene miedo
precisamente de comprometer el
desarrollo económico colombiano ha sido
el ejemplo para bajar la inflación pero
colombia durante las últimas décadas si
bajó sus tasas de pobreza si aumentó la
cobertura en servicios sociales
importantes y creo que ese es nuestro
nuestro sello no un cambio incrementar
la pandemia mounstro digamos la
vulnerabilidad es de crecimiento y las
circunstancias difíciles que vienen una
gran parte de la población pero aquí en
colombia la idea de un estado más grande
no es tan atractiva y creo que cuando
oímos a gustavo petro y nos preocupamos
por eso y me incluyo no creo que sea
algo que sea solo un miedo de los
mercados
sin razones por ejemplo en el tema
del petróleo ha sido difícil para estas
empresas sabemos que estos son contratos
de 10 a 15 años cuando se dice que no se
van a hacer van a buscar más yacimientos
eso implica uno algunos unos gastos y
unas decisiones que pues dado el
presupuesto colombiano y a la estructura
de ese presupuesto pues genera mucha
mucha incertidumbre entonces creo que
que gustavo petro es una apuesta
interesante
claro que hay que reconocer que la
ganancia en términos de derechos
económicos y sociales y lo que él
representa y toda esa digamos simbología
del gobierno petro pero también es
asustadores en ciertos niveles y además
que es claro y lo han dicho durante la
campaña desde el pacto histórico que no
es que se vaya a suspender la extracción
de petróleo los yacimientos que están en
funcionamiento van a seguir funcionando
hasta que se agoten lo que van a hacer
es continuar con la exploración para
buscar nuevos pozos de petróleo para que
colombia siga siendo un país
extractivista de petróleo porque tiene
que hacer una transición energética y
modificar un poco esa matriz económica
de ser un país tan dependiente de la
exportación del petróleo y esto que a
viabilidad tiene theodor es suena muy
lindo en las palabras suena muy lindo
esta defensa del medio ambiente pero
cuatro años hacer una transición
energética no lo ha podido hacer
alemania no lo ha podido hacer dinamarca
que son abanderados en este tema y menos
en un país como colombia y por eso
cambiar la matriz económica en cuatro
años es difícil no
claro muy difícil y yo creo que el
equipo de de petro tiene claro que no
pueden hacer esta transición en cuatro
años pero si quieren digamos lanzar una
transición hacia la nada
yo creo que ya hay que reconocer que el
actual gobierno y gobiernos anteriores
han avanzado mucho en la transición
energética o sea conviene cuatro años
ahora ha notado mucho digamos en el
aumentar la capacidad instalada de
energía solar eólico a través de
subastas en particular entonces yo creo
que o sea hay ya como un base para
construir perpetró actualmente o sea que
quiere buscar acelerar esta transición
y digamos de poco cambia también de
pronto de modelo para digamos las
energías renovables y esto como decía
mónica pues sí puede implicar algunos
digamos riesgos macroeconómicos muy
graves pero ese sentido yo creo que esto
también va a obligar a petro que sea un
poco más pragmático yo creo que sí es
probable que no veamos digamos
nuevas licencias de exploración
vamos a ver nuevos títulos mineros desde
el punto del proceso de licenciamiento
ambiental se pone mucho más complicado
pero yo no creo que va a buscar como
decía frenar proyectos y ya están
produciendo porque al final de cuentas
el gobierno va a necesitar el ingreso y
las regalías que aportan esos 600 me
quieren ya pocos minutos en el tramo
final del programa dos temas para el
cierre
mónica el tema
de la política exterior los
relacionamientos que puedan llevar a
cabo el presidente electo gustavo petro
necesariamente tiene que hablar tiene
que establecer un diálogo con washington
es el gran aliado en la región
dependemos a nivel económico en cierta
forma de este país pero también hay una
necesidad de restablecer cierto punto de
relaciones con venezuela no
necesariamente eso quiere decir que sea
amigo del gobierno que está de turno en
caracas pero también hay una relación
difícil con nicaragua que de pronto
ideológicamente se entienden pero el
diferendo territorial por las aguas en
el caribe pone ahí una mina en el camino
y
en cierta forma colombia podrá retomar
un poco del liderazgo a nivel de la
región
yo creo que en este momento los países
de américa latina tienen tantos dilemas
domésticos que este escenario que vimos
en el pasado donde los crecientes
entonces estaban y no haciendo una
diplomacia mucho más proactiva en unión
de la región y no hace en el escenario
que veamos creo que además los
presidentes
pues que están liderando muchas de las
naciones que tienen esta tendencia
digamos y que podrían ser amigos no
están en las mejores condiciones
internas entonces gustavo petro
efectivamente va a liderar un discurso
que va a hacer que va a ser importante
porque va a plantear un cambio en
términos de la relación con washington
hablemos de no aspersión de cultivos que
es algo que dice que no va a permitir la
guerra contra el narcotráfico
una establecer una coalición
medioambiental con la región pero pero
creo que digamos
este es el punto en donde colombia de
pronto puede empezar a jugar un papel
pero pero como decíamos ese es el socio
principal de eeuu en la región pero creo
que que va a ser limitada esa relación
con los demás países en la región por
las circunstancias en que se encuentran
esa es mi lectura inicial y tengo dar
sólo lectura sobre este tema de la
política exterior muy puntual por favor
para tratar el último tema que es
francia márquez y la vicepresidenta
si yo consigo como comunica que yo no
creo que va a ser prioridad la política
exterior del gobierno de petró yo creo
que pues tenemos que ver realmente va a
poner el tema ambiental en el centro
pero si yo no me quede muy claro cómo va
a funcionar está digamos alianza
regional para la transición energética y
la protección ambiental y que quiere
saber si y tal vez veamos que este
presidente electo puede que no sea el
primer presidente o puede que sea el
primer presidente en colombia que no
tenga este afán por llegar a la casa
blanca estrechar la mano con el
presidente de turno en eeuu puede llegar
a ser un escenario factible durante este
gobierno de cuatro años para el cierre
hablar de francia marc es una figura
importantísima a lo largo de esta
campaña electoral y lo que representa a
ella para la mujer afro colombiana para
la cultura del pacífico de la zona del
cauca en este país en el en el occidente
de colombia lo que representa a ella por
su relación con el conflicto por su
relación con la defensa de los valores y
de la cultura
en colombia impresiones mónica
pues a mí me parece que definitivamente
estamos viendo un cambio en la
estructura del gobierno cuando uno es
las personas que están que llegaron a
esta segunda vuelta ninguna de ellas
tiene apellidos que reconozcamos en
gobernantes anteriores
hablamos de diversidad
francia es todo un símbolo para las
feministas colombianas para todas las
mujeres que están luchando en contra
digamos de tener una circunstancia de
subordinación entonces creo que es una
muy buena noticia creo que sí va a
generar una relación tensionante con
gustavo petro sus posiciones son mucho
más radicales
gustavo petro no tiene una reputación de
escuchar y ahí entonces vamos a ver yo
creo que una relación que puede
evolucionar muy bien si se sabe manejar
y capitalizar pero puede que también
genere ruido al interior del gobierno
como lo pasó a gustavo petro con ángela
maría robledo y con algunos de sus
aliados más cercanos esperemos que eso
no ocurra pero pues definitivamente
las mujeres en colombia estamos muy
contentas de ver este en este nuevo
escenario en la isla imposible es muy
representativo siendo de alguna para la
historia política de colombia ti va a
dar un minuto para sus impresiones sobre
la vicepresidenta electa
bueno no sé yo nuevamente yo creo que sí
hacer de importancia es simbólica de
francia- márquez no lo podemos
subestimar
pero sí creo que va a ser muy
interesante y definitivo ver cómo va a
ser
en el gobierno actualmente representa
digamos esas demandas y exigencias
sociales más radicales y es posible que
esto puede ser un factor que lo hace más
difícil
digamos en el momento de buscar alianzas
con sectores más moderados ustedes puede
ser muy interesante ver como esa
atención se recuerde por lo menos hay
una representación en el gobierno de
esos sectores afectados a lo largo de
todas estas décadas por el conflicto
armado por el narcotráfico por los
grupos delincuenciales hay alguien ya en
casa de nariño que habla por ellos con
conocimiento de causa eso es algo que
hay que decir que vale la pena destacar
de estas elecciones presidenciales en
colombia 7 de agosto es la fecha de
posesión del nuevo gobierno en colombia
gustavo petro ella recibirá entonces la
banda presidencial y asumirá ya el cargo
como presidente de colombia y a partir
de ahí pues comenzará a escribirse este
nuevo capítulo en la historia política
de ese país ya veremos qué pasa por
supuesto estaremos aquí en france24
haciendo el análisis de los
acontecimientos en colombia mónica de
activador les agradezco mucho haber
estado con nosotros para hacer este
análisis para las personas que están
fuera de las fronteras colombianas que
nos ven desde otros países y ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales de france 24 por supuesto
sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]